[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is the video on the chapter
about the Catalan so the Catalan opening
is an important part of our repertoire
because it will very frequently be on
the board because after deform I've 93
I'd have six we play d3 and very often
black will play with e6 there should be
seven most of the time and Castle and
after C form we will get what we usually
call a Catalan yeah what exactly is a
Catalan by the way and we should define
that the normal move order for the
Catalan looks like this
REME I've posted they cohere night of
three assaults assaults well is the most
common position in the catalan and the
catalan is usually characterized by this
central pour information upon formation
is also well known in the Queens gambit
declined but with white having
fianchetto would instead of choosing one
classical set up with Knight c3 and
Bishop g5 and III for example in our
move autumn we delay the move C form but
ultimately this will be the main
position that we will study in our
chapter here in this part of our
repertoire as well so our way our way to
get to this wood beam and in three
narrow 6-2 3-6 should be two which
should be 7s floor Castle C form and we
get to this position that we just looked
at
now after D form d5 Knight f3 black does
not necessarily need to play Knight f6
first to be in this chapter or to
transpose into lines of this chapter
they can also play a 6 that is possible
but it doesn't have much independent
value and we simply play g3 Bishop g2
all of the time and if black plays some
Knight f6 which should be 7 or Bishop d6
Weaver transpose of course um all
through this chapter there are ways for
black to opt out of a Catalan yeah they
can all the time let's say after Knight
f6 g3 e6 Bishop g2 black could play a
move like b5 for example which is a
separate chapter the end time
c4 chapter about b5 setups or they could
play c5 Castle stakes and this is
reversed
Grune felt so it's only the Catalan in
this chapter if black is not going on
early c5 or b5 or for that matter also
already b6 which after four examples
here here here is a
Queens Indian so we are um talking about
lines where black is first and foremost
trying to develop the kingside and
castle
quickly now d5 9003 as mentioned is six
is purely transpositional in that regard
we play after Knight f6 the move g3 and
now is six is the way to castle as
quickly as possible so we play Bishop to
g2 now an important point to mention
again I already did in the intro chapter
but about the general or a concept is to
mention that here the move C form would
be a mainline ethyl on a traditional
more common move order for the Catalan
the difference about playing this here
or Bishop g2 is mostly two lines that
black now has available the first one is
the move Bishop before check which
enjoys a very solid reputation the idea
of this checker said after the normal
reply Bishop d2 black goes back to e7
and then yes basically claiming that
this extra move does her word white and
in some regards this is definitely true
if we later examine the close Catalan
when we do that we'll see that very
often this is a good spot for the night
and the bishop often wants to be on b2
rather so this is a slightly annoying
line but more problematic from a
repertoire perspective is the move take
C form
and this gives a black-white choice
after the best reply Bishop g2 here
black has a million I mean that's a
slight exaggeration but not so much he's
got tons of moves he's got b5 a 696
Bishop d7 97 and so on check again yeah
c6 or whatever it's it's it's it's
amazing
let him play all kinds of things and
often times it gets rather sharp and
concrete with white being a pawn down
and you're playing in gambit style this
is not bad for white please don't
misunderstand me yeah it's not bad for
white but it is a really huge
theoretical effort and I prefer to not
allow this with them move order Bishop
g2 we can do exactly that
the only drawback of this move order
would be that black now has these
opportunities of c5 or b5 which we have
dealt in other chapters and I mean this
is interesting these moves are
interesting on black but I think I
provided enough interesting ideas in the
other chapters to item and this is
basically the price you pay or yeah
avoiding lots of very theoretical - very
theoretical lines after C form so if you
at the latest stage want to actually
allow that - yeah get into those sharp
lines not a bad thing
doom in the long run just for varieties
sake so we play Bishop d2 and now here
the main options for black that we need
to check in this chapter are Bishop e7
and - Bishop to d6 those two
developments are very natural um again
there are many ways for black to
transpose outside of this of the chapter
like c5 and b5 and b6 as we said now
things that we need to check out as I
said mostly the - bishop moves but there
are two other lines that are worth
checking one is the move Knight to c6
that looks odd yeah I agree but it is
seen sometime in particular on the club
level now the important thing you to
remember is that we Castle first we
usually do so this is not a big deal
it's just that if we somehow
accidentally would play c4 here black
has the option to capture which leads us
into one of those sharp gambit style
lines um often times gambit style you
know you don't have to sacrifice every
time but still this is something that I
want to avoid so we simply cancel as we
usually do and now black will probably
play there should be seven or Bishop d6
um and yeah a quick look at those lines
doesn't hurt we definitely now want to
play c4 this is just a matter of timing
we want c4 we just wait um until a good
moment arises p.m. we should be quite
nicely better if black now castles we
play Knight bTW - about the pawn and in
the long run we can prepare the movie
four which is a standard IDM in the
epsilon um this is just an important
thing to consider the bishop on g2 is
just better than the bishop on c8 and
often the bishop here can be helpful in
supporting me for later so this is very
nice for us um black can also take but
after 92 we are not having any problems
to get the pawn back and then we
definitely would be better and they
cannot play b5 because of the very
direct reply 95 and the diagonal here is
of course a big problem if black plays
Knight takes d4 we shouldn't even take
on a eight and this is hanging so we
have a better option we just take here
and this is great advantage
a white yeah like takes Queen takes we
see that
and there's just too much going on now
this is completely hanging and tonight
c6 is also in the position so this is
completely terrible um in comparison
after this Bishop e7 looks a little bit
better but white is still of course
better we play c4 and now the only
somewhat interesting move is maybe to
take if they if they don't take we have
the easy plan again of going 90 to maybe
a three to prevent any night before most
after Quincy - yeah and ultimately
Quincy - II forms the standard plan that
we will see a lot also in any closed
Catalin that will come up relatively
best maybe is the capture after which
Queen a form is going to be good for
white because we get the pawn back and
um something like this is definitely
better for awesome we have this extra
sent a pawn like dat pawn against just
the e pawn and the only thing that you
need to do is do not trade too much yeah
for example after 25
please don't take on d5 but rather move
the Queen away and gain an additional
empo on the black Queen but we don't
want to trade
[Music]